le procès villemin audience émouvante
étendu cet après-midi devant la cour
d'assises de la côte d'or avec le
témoignage très attendu de marie-ange
laroche la veuve de la victime et en
présence de christine villemin
un face-à-face douloureux compte rendu
d'audience dominique verdeilhan bruno
girodon images choc de cette 7e
audiences au fond de la salle d'assises
christine villemin avec ses avocats au
premier plan en manteau bleu marie ange
laroche
le face à face entre deux femmes entre
deux victimes durant plus de deux heures
marie-ange laroche a revécu son drame
j'ai vu wilm avec un fusil il a dit
c'est ta faute s'ils sont sur christine
je te comprends jean-marie mais je te
jure ce n'est pas moi qui ai tué ton
gosse lui a répondu bernard avant de
s'effondrer le pull taché de sang
bernard a agonisé sous mes yeux est
devant son fils sébastien âgé de 4 ans
le soir j'ai su que j'étais de nouveau
enceinte mariage qui à dijon veut
défendre la mémoire de son mari ses
impression qu on associe les bernois
parce qu'elle venait d'être innocenté
c'est ce que je ressens
et je suis comme beaucoup de personnes
comme bernard le volet aussi c'est de
savoir la vérité sur la mort du petit
grégory toute façon ce taux ressort
c'est que comme la tuer physiquement
veut m'assassiner moralement j'ai
l'impression que tu es moins moralement
à la barre christine villemin raconte
que la mort de bernard laroche
elle la frise alors qu'elle était
hospitalisée après avoir rappelé que
quatre jours plus tôt les experts
avaient désigné christine villemin comme
étant le corbeau m front s'en prend à la
mère de grégory
vous maniez le sens et là vous vous avez
poussé votre mari a tué la roche
supporter les conséquences
en face m au garrot bondi vous injuriez
une innocente c'est scandaleux
nous irons jusqu'au bout nous allons
démontrer que bernard laroche a bien
enlevé l'enfant les changes entre les
deux avocats et vif
il ne s'agit pas seulement des effets de
manche il a aussi le mérite de révéler
au grand jour la stratégie de deux
parties et d'apporter aussi aux jurés
une confirmation après neuf ans
d'errements la justice les met au pied
du mur
certes les 12 jurés ont un seul homme a
jugé
mais deux affaires à élucider